in opa for Europe and especially Germany
has often criticized Hungary's
government our guest this week is Alton
bolic a minister in this government and
a close associate of Prime Minister
Viktor Orban hello hello to you healthy
I'd like to welcome our viewers to the
DW interview my name is Alexandra
phenomenal mr. Bullock in the past your
government has been criticized for its
many changes to hungary's constitution
its controversial media laws and lately
for its refugee policy have you grown
immune to this criticism I mean it up a
stinker the sphere I think we've proven
ourselves in the face of criticism we
have carefully examined every issue that
has been raised and i can say with a
clear conscience that hungry is the only
country in europe whose entire legal
system has been vetted by brussels by
the European Court of Justice and its
judicial organs and they have all
determined that hungry fulfills the
criteria of the rule of law in every way
there were three or four points where we
were not in compliance and we have since
altered these laws and the Constitution
so I can say no country has been is
closely inspected and is as transparent
in its laws as hungry is the coffee
because that's cable tiger the division
that means the criticism was helpful in
changing laws stator is a good process
yet I do think it's problematic that it
has only been applied to Hungary month
or cat's life one shouldn't apply double
standards but we accepted the fact that
we had to go through the process after
the initial fuss we accepted the
criticism with composure we consulted
with the European Commission and
President Barroso was a big help in
ensuring that the procedure was fair
that's a file and I think the final
result is good for Europe good for
Hungary good for our citizens and good
for the law so I think that's a positive
balance thankful that you got me Lance
so what in particular Hungary's policy
toward refugees was criticized and on
some points vehemently for example that
Hungary built a fence on the border to
keep refugees out do you think this was
necessary uh the Casa means own i hate
the fence but it was necessary i think
both of these aspects are important
because otherwise people will get a
false impression that we Hungarians like
to live between fences or behind fences
we don't but unfortunately the European
institutions reacted too late or not at
all so we were forced to build the fence
in order to comply with the European
laws this is a different issue from
those of the Constitution and the media
law I think hungary has just been
unjustly criticised for something that
only Hungary could do for something we
were prepared to do to comply with the
European regulations but you used water
cannons and tear gas against refugees uh
dr. Stein einziger father you're
speaking about a single case and it was
brought before the court when we first
said no this stream of refugees must be
stopped the response was an attack on
our border installations that was
clearly a provocation and unfortunately
the police had to resort to these means
but it's not an isolated case in Europe
including in regard to refugees
unfortunately that's what happened today
we're investigating the degree to which
human traffickers acted as manipulative
provocateurs deevak after the Bible but
there are also many other examples that
reveal a certain tendency in your
refugee policy for example a campaign in
which posters warn migrants against
taking jobs away from Hungarians was
that necessary the name about a snort
wendys that's me this eigen time will
tell Hungary's position on refugee
policy is a rigorous no we think hungary
is already bearing the greatest burden
it can with tasks that have to do with
integrating the refugees that have
already been accepted and we want to
develop in a different direction
culturally but I think we have complied
with every humanitarian
regulation as a minister who is
partially responsible i have often
personally double checked to ensure that
this is the case on site at the border
we have done everything that needs to be
done for the refugees legally and in
terms of humanitarianism the warden
gitane the 0 veu wants to distribute
refugees according to quotas hungary
says this increases the risk of
terrorist attacks and in dangers our
culture doesn't that sound like populism
feel itís before maybe it still sounded
like populism a year ago but today we
have the proof one quite an uncontrolled
wave of migrants moved through Europe
several hundred thousand people move
through our country with its population
of nine and a half million today we know
that people involved in the attacks in
Paris Brussels and elsewhere came in
this uncontrolled wave of refugees
through Hungary and Austria to Germany
and from Germany to France efficient so
I think unfortunately terrorism and
migrations are connected as a stinker
that's the reason with lumigan I don't
want to discredit people who are
legitimately seeking asylum because they
have really been persecuted or to deny
them their rights well that you're right
I know that but that's the impression
you create when you mix these topics we
don't mix them the terrorists mix them
we have to differentiate and we have to
make sure that we stop these tendencies
I know how to beat them as ministers as
a minister in the government you are
responsible for many areas including
health education and social welfare but
you also studied theology and have
worked as a Protestant pastor how do you
reconcile Hungary's refugee policy with
the commandment to love your neighbor
and to help the weak nutrition I'm so
heavy you think he and I think help
should be given to everyone who needs
individual help not only as a minister i
guess but also as a theologian and
christian i have supported eight
organizations and hungary and carrying
out their tasks
luckily there is another area in which
we have a conflict the integration of
the roma hungry placed this task on the
EU agenda in 2011 when we held the
council presidency it is a task we have
to perform we have to do more to carry
it out in Central and Eastern Europe in
Hungary Romania Slovakia and the Czech
Republic in all these countries but now
Brussels says that the funds we have
allotted for integrating the Roma should
be divided and diverted to cover the
refugees as well this sends the wrong
signal and I think we have to set
priorities and defend our ability to
carry out the tasks we have already set
ourselves on the individual level you're
right Christians can't turn away from
the commandment to love their neighbor
Nathan liebe the Sistine angry bought
food but at the same time the state has
the task of protecting the security of
its citizens these two things belong
together and yet can and must be
distinguished zombie haroon Christina
shiny on Canal how can you explain why
you defend Hungary's rigorous refugee
policy yet continued your private
efforts in the refugee aid Zeb sniffling
sue for anger GM yep it's finally nice
to this migration is not good for Europe
on a structural level that is my
political analysis and I have to use
political and diplomatic means to find a
solution so that Europe is no longer put
under pressure this way that personally
I'm involved in the integration of the
Roma and in dealing with refugees and
their I show my you mane and Christian
side why should these two things be
contradictory I see no contradiction we
have to operate under two tracks and
take both issues seriously theta chi
unesco as a politician in the government
I'm responsible for the state's duty to
protect its citizens and the integrity
of the country and as a private person
and as a Christian I practice love of my
neighbor image that it needs to leave in
practice even see I why you weren't
close
with Viktor Orban how would you describe
your relationship good are you friends
is that my shot at the moment he's my
boss that's not always good for
friendship but we've known each other
for almost 30 years I'm very good
friends with him and his family people
say you fasted together is your
relationship that close yeah yes it is
why do you like him its global what I
miss in Europe and here I won't use the
German word but the English one is
leadership I think people have the right
to be led in such a way that a clear
stance can be recognized that a leader
finds clear words for their situation
and for the future as Viktor Orban does
I know him well as someone who unlike
the general opinion about him can be
persuaded by reasonable and good
arguments and who can concede when he's
persuaded I also know him as someone I
can't always convince and who then turns
out to have been right Victor oba victim
or bond doesn't hide the fact that he
doesn't think much of Western values
that he admires Putin and the Chinese
model more than the Western one which he
considers decadent what do you say to
that doesn't Viktor Orban never used
those words it's just not true at how to
blow machine i think you said in a
speech that countries that do not use
our Western liberal democratic model can
be successful too he mentioned Singapore
and other countries and if you look at
the economic statistics of China or
Singapore Russia is a special case then
you see that these countries are indeed
successful but he also always said that
that cannot be a model for us in Europe
because we're committed to democracy
livia their democratic effective thing
simplistic we always end our DW
interview with three unfinished
sentences please complete them first I
went into politics because irvine ish i
wanted to represent the cultural values
that preserved our country in the last
1000 years and particularly
Protestantism which preserved us in the
last 500
do you think is een and what I like
about Germany is risen shaft science and
scholarship I studied here I enjoy
German culture hurdling and other poets
and the wonderful music of Johann
Sebastian Bach but i also like debating
with some politicians here política
favorite when was the next time
germany's chancellor angela merkel
visits hungary Don vanity I'll remind
her of the times when she was still an
East German girl if I'm a caller this
who visited Hungary and bought milk and
bread at a little corner stand on the
banks of the Danube Yakov that is our
common Eastern and Central European
history that we must not forget because
what we learned back then in that
situation has to be represented in the
common European house asia house alpha
east and west in a new relationship I
think that's very important for the
future if you disapproved mr. Bullock
thank you thank you very much